es como si la plaza italia empezará a
prepararse miles de personas protestaron
por esta emblemática locación en la
previa del primer aniversario de un
estallido social que ni la misma
pandemia ha conseguido menguar este
viernes una multitud volvió a acelerar
las calles bajo la demanda de vivir en
una sociedad más equitativa aunque hubo
choques con la policía el escenario fue
menos violento que otras protestas
vividas este año el 2019 terminó de una
manera muy distinta el 18 de octubre una
movilización liderada por los
estudiantes en contra del alza en el
billete del metro terminó en una ola de
protestas en contra del gobierno bajo la
bandera del descontento social 31
muertos 30.000 detenidos y 8 mil 800
querellas contra agentes del estado
pusieron la lupa sobre las autoridades
más internacional considera que el uso
excesivo de la fuerza en contextos de
protesta y como resultado la violación
generalizada del derecho a la integridad
personal no habría sido posible si los
altos mandos de carabineros hubieran
ejercido un adecuado control de sus
subordinados mientras el gobierno
asegura que en la
no se perdonan los abusos a personas
como diego les cuesta pasar la página el
año pasado perdió su ojo tras la
explosión de una bomba lacrimógena
el pecho
y alegría porque
en el horizonte no sólo está el
aniversario del domingo sino también el
plebiscito del 25 de octubre para
definirse habrá una nueva constitución
esa era una demanda de los manifestantes
y se muestra como un logro pero que no
cerrará cicatrices de personas como
diego